accountable let's get a response now
from heidi joe castro she's in
washington dc heidi so uh president
biden uh coming out now making that
statement saying russia's unprovoked and
unjustified attack on ukraine what more
did he have to say
that's right darren and since then there
has been yet another statement from the
white house this worded by the president
himself following a phone call that
president biden had with the president
of ukraine and in it i'll just read it
to you president biden says president
zielinski reached out to me tonight and
we just finished speaking this is right
before midnight
washington time i condemn the unprovoked
and unjustified attack by russian
military forces i briefed him on the
steps we are taking to rally
international condemnation including
tonight at the u.n security council
president zielinski asked president
biden to call on the leaders of the
world to speak out clearly against
president putin's flagrant aggression
and biden goes on to say and to stand
with the people of ukraine tomorrow i
will be meeting with the leaders of the
g7 and the united states and our allies
and partners will be imposing severe
sanctions on russia we will continue to
provide support and assistance to
ukraine
and the ukrainian people and tomorrow is
when president biden has a scheduled
call with the g7 leaders and he we're
expecting him to announce this full raft
of sanctions against russia around noon
time to the american people darren heidi
so yeah let's just stick with those
issues uh in terms of sanctions and
response um because as part of
biden's reaction statement he said that
the u.s its allies and partners will
respond
in a united and decisive way so now
we're talking about further sanctions
what will those sanctions look like do
we think
right we don't have exact details but
today the white house did say that there
would be no financial institution in
russia that is safe from these potential
sanctions we know what the white house
with the u.s has levied thus far only
accounts for the first raft of sanctions
those are sanctions targeting the north
stream two pipeline as well as two
russian banks and the sovereign debt so
there has been a lot of room for further
maneuvering in terms of financial
sanctions what they may be targeting
further financial institutions in russia
and there's talk of the treasury
department uh have
export bans on u.s technology to russia
which could hurt as well but what's also
telling in the statement not only from
biden but also from
a statement from the u.s secretary of
state anthony lincoln is that now the
u.s and allies will be meeting not only
to talk about how to punish russia for
having taken this action
but now further deterrence further
deterrence that will shore up the nato
allies
the
we know that the defense secretary as
well as the the u.s state secretary will
be meeting we'll be talking with nato
tomorrow to discuss that very issue how
to further deter russia from potentially
attacking nato territory hardy let me
get a final thought from you i mean how
is this crisis playing out politically
uh for president biden i mean he faces
accusations
of being weak over russia and that these
latest u.s sanctions which were
announced a few days ago all rather
tepid and ineffective is this proving to
be his most difficult foreign policy
challenge yet do we think
well at this point congress is actually
giving bipartisan support to the
president which is a rare thing these
days but we're hearing statements from
senators of both parties saying that the
u.s and its allies must respond to
russia's aggression in a way that's
decisive and devastating so the two
parties democrats and republicans are
united so far in backing the white
house's actions on this yes like you
said darren there has been criticism
about when the sanctions should have
been levied perhaps earlier as more of a
deterrence but now that russia has taken
this adversarial step as it's perceived
here in washington uh it seems like most
of congress both parties are united
behind the president's actions all right
how does your castro live for us there
in uh washington dc i think yes it is
heidi thank
you well fighting has been ongoing in
eastern ukraine for years in 2014
separatists carved out territory
highlighted in yellow from ukraine's
donetsk and lugansk provinces they
declared their own people's republics
which are recognized only by themselves
and now russia
overall about 2 million people live in
doniak's province and a million and a
half live in lugansk many especially in
the rebel-controlled areas have obtained
russian passports both provinces are
industrial hubs dominated by mining with
vast coal reserves an important asset
for all sides it's estimated at least 14
000 people have been killed in fighting
for control of the regions in the past
eight years
so let's see now some of the televised
address that russian president vladimir
putin made as he announced the military
action earlier and told ukrainian forces
to retreat
we urge you to lay down arms immediately
and go home i will explain all
servicemen of the ukrainian army who
comply with this requirement can freely
leave the area of military actions and
return to their families
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history we are ready for
any outcome
all right let's go live again to dawson
jabari in the russian capital um dorsa
so uh russian president vladimir putin
ordering what he's calling this special
operation um in the donbass region of
eastern ukraine he says the operation is
to protect civilians there what more
details have emerged about the military
operation first
well as you can imagine the russian
military is very
tight-lipped about what is taking place
on the ground
with uh their borders of uh with ukraine
now you have to remember this country
shares a border with ukraine
is about 2 300 kilometers of that is uh
the 300 kilometers that is a sea border
and about 2 000 of that is a land border
and i think what we're hearing now
reports of uh the russian military going
in from various sides
of ukraine from the east from the west
and now from the north in belarus
allegedly
it's clear that this is not just any
operation a small military operation in
the eastern region of donbass as the
president had said
what will be the reason for all of this
we'll have to wait and see because many
of
the residents here in moscow i spoke to
yesterday commemorating what is their
version of remembrance day here in
russia
they said that they couldn't possibly
fathom the idea of going to war with
ukraine ukraine is their neighbor it's
part of their family they're all
brothers and sisters and there really is
no justification for
launching a full-scale attack on ukraine
at this time they said that this was all
rhetoric but now we see what is
unfolding uh in the images that are
we're seeing now a full-scale uh attack
in ukraine
yeah dorsa and as we've seen over the
last few days uh the language coming
from
the russian president vladimir putin
became even more hard it became more
bombastic talk us through uh for our
viewers who are just tuning in to al
jazeera now the sequence of events the
timeline
over the last couple of days in terms of
putin's moves in eastern ukraine what
happened right up until today
well this all began with an
extraordinary session of vladimir
putin's
security council on monday we saw a
about an hour and a half video of that
meeting that had taken place earlier in
the day and it was very interesting
because nobody in this country very few
people had seen these high-ranking
officials ever speak in public and they
were answering questions to the
president who had a number of questions
for them about various things about the
country's security about the military
about sanctions he asked sergey lavrov
what are the status of western sanctions
and lavrov told him that
basically the west is going to impose
sanctions on us no matter what we do um
and then a few hours later there was an
address to the nation that was also a
tape message that was broadcast on state
tv by vladimir putin on monday evening
in which he declared independence
recognition for the separatists regions
of donetsk and lugansk in eastern
ukraine those separatist leaders were
also present with vladimir putin at the
kremlin where they signed official
decrees and that decree went to the duma
that is the state legislature here on
tuesday and parliamentarians
solidified putin's decision they
verified it and then at the same time we
heard from the upper house of parliament
here where they said they had a request
from the president to be able to deploy
troops wherever whenever he seemed fit
and parliamentarians in the upper house
voted unanimously 153 of them to grant
vladimir putin permission to
send russian military troops
anywhere in the world at any time that
he saw it was necessary i think that was
the point where we realized it was
inevitable that some kind of a conflict
would occur
but on
wednesday evening we heard from the
separatist leaders in those regions in
eastern ukraine asking the russian
military for assistance saying that they
were under attack and that is the
decision that was then taken by vladimir
putin at six am local time in moscow
where we heard the president saying that
he was sending a military unit um
deployment of troops to donbass to
assist the separatists there of course
what we're seeing now unfold is a much
broader scale
invasion of ukraine since that
announcement was broadcast and i think a
lot of people
will be very shocked at the images and
the news once the city is fully um awake
dawson we're just hearing uh from the
reuters news agency from the ukrainians
who say they've shot down uh a military
aircraft in ukraine obviously that's
that's just coming to me now i'm hearing
it here so you so you probably haven't
heard it in moscow yet
um however let me ask you um is it is it
perhaps too early to start making an
assessment of of the scale and the scope
of the russian military operation we
know we have this issue of the special
operation in the donbass region uh as as
as part of the military umbrella
operations we have this shock and awe in
terms of the other big ukrainian cities
but is it too early to start talking
about the scope and scale of the
operation just yet and
what would be the objectives then
well vladimir putin had said in the past
and reiterated this week and all the
speeches that he's made to this nation
and the world that he wants ukraine to
lay down their arms they want to
demilitarize ukraine and they don't
believe ukraine should exist as a
sovereign nation and that the leadership
in kiev is very weak and being used as a
puppet by western countries
and i think we expect this to continue
for at least another week we've just
heard from russian officials who have
said that
they are temporarily suspending flights
to a number of airports until the early
hours of march 2nd so i think that gives
us an indication of how long we can
expect this to go on as to
what russia is trying to achieve i think
it's clear now that they want to take
full control of this country because
they see it as their
ambitions to join nato as very much a
threat which is what got us here really
in the first place according to the
russians they didn't want nato to expand
further eastwards and certainly didn't
want
ukraine to become a member of nato and
now we're seeing the events unfold on
the ground there as a result of what
vladimir putin had called very much a
security threat to this country i want
to say um that on monday evening during
his first televised address address to
the nation where he declared those two
states as independent states in eastern
ukraine vladimir putin said to the west
that
you didn't want us to become friends but
you didn't have to make an enemy of us
and i think those words now are very
much um becoming clear what is unfolding
um what we're seeing now in the
coming hours in the past few hours that
we've seen vladimir putin very much
feels that he was cornered and now he
has taken things really to the extreme
daughter just a just a final thought to
you you were saying that yesterday
russia celebrated its its equivalent of
remembrance uh day uh remembering those
killed in past conflicts how do how do
ordinary russians people on the street
feel about uh what is a
a massive operation now in neighboring
ukraine and many many russians live in
ukraine when ukrainians live in russia
these you know both sides have historic
cultural connections going back for many
many many many years and centuries how
do ordinary russians think about what's
going on
well i think um in the coming hours
it'll be much more clear but i i really
believe that the initial response will
be shock i don't think most russians
will believe vladimir putin has decided
to take this um decision to this scale i
think
many of the analysts i was speaking to
over the past few weeks and i've been
here now for nearly seven weeks and i
think many people initially when i
arrived in russia in early january the
concept or the prospect of any kind of
conflict on any scale was completely
preposterous to everybody i spoke to and
over the past two weeks it's become a
different narrative many analysts said
that they believed some kind of an
incursion was possible given what had
happened on the diplomatic front
but the ordinary russians actually from
the beginning until now until yesterday
they refused to believe that this was
ever going to happen they said there is
no reason for russia to invade ukraine
there's no reason for russia to launch a
full-scale attack on ukraine there is no
sensible justification
for this to happen and i think
vladimir putin has laid out his reason
whether or not the russian population
will be able to fathom that and accept
that
we'll be
asking them in the coming hours and i
think it will be very difficult for them
to really get behind this decision at
this point because this war
will have um
casualties and i think those casualties
will be massive
and the people we spoke to yesterday who
were remembering those soldiers that
have uh lost their lives in previous
wars said that we have hoped we've heard
learned our lessons um from the past and
they won't be repeated but i think
today's events make it clear that those
lessons have not been learned all right
adorable live for us there in moscow
door so thank you for that let's cross
her back now to ukraine's capital kiev
uh and talk to andrew simmons andrew
we've been talking to you uh for the
last couple of hours uh when the bombs
started falling just bring us up to date
uh with what's happening now what have
you been seeing and hearing in the last
few minutes or so
well there has been a fairly large
explosion just just recently you weren't
sure whether that was outgoing fire or
incoming uh quite nearby but there's
been a
something of a lull this past hour air
raid sirens
were wailing away in the city uh and a
picture is becoming a bit clearer now um
it would appear that the center of the
city
is
has not been attacked it would appear
that military installations have been
the target
and there have been missile attacks uh
bombing burial bombing we think but
that's not being confirmed uh and
the
casualties and the levels of damage is
unclear but the whole
sky was
awash with with red and orange when
these missiles struck apparently they
were some of them were cruise missiles
and the um the main international
airport uh did come under attack um it's
unclear what the damage is there but all
airspace is closed uh we've heard from
president uh vladimir zelinsky
he actually took to facebook to announce
what was happening he just
seemed to be in a safe place in his own
residence um he said russia was uh uh
conducting uh strikes uh and uh
and and and shelling on the military
infrastructure of his country he
declared martial law
he said we are strong
we are
ready for anything we will win
and now
how that came across
with the traumatized people of this city
is unclear what we're seeing right now
is
some families with bags
evidently moving out i just seen some
children uh taking their pets their
hamsters their dogs and their mother and
father walking alongside it is very
likely that people will actually leave
this city
in what sort of numbers we're unsure but
it has to be said people
apparently have been panicking in the
city center because the sheer
sound of these explosions it was rocking
uh the city echoing around the buildings
it it it was very very terrifying for
people who
are used to this sort of thing although
having said that um ukraine is pretty
resilient place because they've had this
hybrid war with russia for eight years
now 14 000 people dead that in the in
the donbass region
really which is really the whole heart
of what's happening now now let me just
try and bring you up to date with where
the
main attacks have been uh here in the
capital uh um we are also hearing um a
number of cities in the east uh mario
pole on the coast uh the sea of azov
there's been the russian navy have been
landing troops and armory
reportedly in odessa that's the main
naval base for ukraine but a very weak
navy which was really taken apart by the
annexation of crimea by the russians in
2014
so that was something that that was was
overrun fairly quickly it would seem um
other attacks
we hear
in khaki
which is a big city uh to the south and
we don't know what levels of damage
there but it would appear that it's
military infrastructure that has been
the main target of uh
attacks by air land and sea all right
andrew simmons live for us there uh in
the ukrainian capital kiev andrew stay
safe thanks for now
well
let's just